américa latina es ahora la región mas
vacunada del mundo
después del duro golpe de la llegada del
cob y 19 en 2020 que ubicó a brasil como
el segundo país con mayor mortalidad
agoto los suministros de oxígeno en perú
y colapsó las morgues de ecuador hoy la
región cuenta con casi un 63 por ciento
de adultos completamente inmunizados
según cifras de hardware in data
expertos afirman que la experiencia
ganada previamente con las campañas de
vacunación masivas que se han realizado
en varios países de américa latina han
sido la clave del éxito de la rápida
inoculación de la región la dosis de
refuerzo por ejemplo es ahora la campaña
a la que los gobiernos le están
apostando con más fuerza ante el brote
de la variante o micro en el mundo a
cobertura masnou brightview tenga un
franz al mundo la cobertura de la
vacunación en brasil ha llegado a muchas
personas y esta es una noticia muy
importante porque con la llegada de la
variante omicron anticipamos la dosis de
refuerzo para muchas personas y creemos
que esto reducirá en gran medida la
mortalidad y las hospitalizaciones
debido a los casos de kobe 19
louis la difusión e invitación constante
a vacunarse por medio de campañas
masivas novedosas han sido eficaces
países a pesar de que el presidente de
la república ya ir bolsonaro es uno de
los principales líderes en contra de la
vacuna en brásil la población brasileña
ya está acostumbrada a muchas campañas
de vacunación y se están vacunando
masivamente y
sin embargo los expertos afirman que
américa latina no puede bajar la guardia
ante la inminente variante o micro que
amenaza con dejar obsoletas algunas
vacunas